[موسيقى]
سينمائي كبير تشارك به السعوديه في مهرجان
كان السينمائي بدورته السادسه والسبعين
حيث شارك نجوم العالم في العرض الاول
لفيلم الافتتاح جندباغي للمخرج الفرنسيه
وبطوله النجم الامريكي جنديف وهو من انتاج
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه هو فرنسا طبعا
احنا اليوم في مهرجان كان
وطبعا امس شاهدنا اول اشتراك انتاجي من
صندوق البحر الاحمر
لفيلم فرنسي جون جباري فيلم الافتتاح فكنا
كلنا موجودين كفريق عمل الفيلم النجوم
جوني دابو المخرج شيء واضح انه قاعد نرتبط
مع السينما العالميه والفرص قاعد تكبر
والحين كل احد يعرف انه السينما السعوديه
صارت ارض خطيبه لهذا المجال
وللسنه الثالثه على تواليه تحضر السعوديه
في مهرجان كان السينمائي في سوق المهرجان
حيث تستقبل الخيمه السعوديه نجوم وصناع
السينما العالميه لتوقيع الاتفاقيات بين
الشركات العالميه المنتجه للسينما وسيتم
تكريم سته فنانات من العالم العربي
وافريقيا باحتفاليه للسينما السعوديه
اول شيء الدعم لا محدود ولا منقطع يعني
قاعدين احنا قاعدين نلاقي دعم من كل مكان
ونردسي من اهم الداعمين لنا بصراحه كنا
محتاجين الفرص هذه وكنا محتاجين انه احنا
نوصل صوتنا للعالم نوصل الاعمالنا للعالم
نوري العالم قديش عندنا ناس مبدعين وناس
فعلا موهوبين والحمد لله يعني قاعدين نحضر
بالدعم وقاعدين نحاول نكون على قدر
المسؤوليه وان شاء الله باذن الله السنه
الجايه راح يكون في اشياء بتفرح العالم
العربي كله باذن الله على مدى ايام
المهرجان ستشهد هذه الخيمه ورشا عملا
وعرضا لافلام السعوديه امام الشركات وصناع
السينما الاعلاميه من اجل اشراك هذه
الافلام في المهرجانات والملتقيات
العالميه اجتماعاتهم واللقاءات مستمره
للسينما القادمين من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هنا في هذه الخيمه في مهرجان كان
لتبادل الخبرات وتوقيع الاتفاقيات بين
مختلف السينمائيين العالمين المشاركين في
المهرجان هذا العام سعد المسعود العربيه
مهرجان كان السينما الدولي جنوب فرنسا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات